[Música]
luego de 20 años continuos en el poder
el presidente de Turquía reyecta y
verdoán por primera vez no gana
ampliamente unas elecciones A diferencia
de los dos comicios pasados no le sacó
más de 10 puntos porcentuales de ventaja
a su rival más cercano que esta vez es
que mal quilish el aspirante por la
alianza nacional que congrega a seis
partidos opositores de hecho erdogan
todavía no ha ganado en primera vuelta y
todo apunta a que podría haber un
segundo balotaje vamos a Estambul donde
está Carlos Ortega Sánchez doctorando en
política y relaciones internacionales de
la Universidad de Estambul y colaborador
en el orden mundial Carlos Gracias por
acompañarnos primero hablemos de Cómo
interpretar estos resultados porque ya
como lo decíamos es la primera vez que
adoba no gana tan ampliamente y segundo
porque todavía no hay un anuncio oficial
Cómo interpretar todo esto Bueno la
verdad es que es difícil interpretar
Porque todavía se están contando si
ponemos la televisión turca ahora mismo
están al 99% Y probablemente se concluya
realmente qué ha pasado mañana
en cualquier caso vemos por un lado un
erdogan que es verdad ha salido más
debilitado él quería ganar en la primera
ronda y no ha podido ser vamos seguro a
una segunda ronda en dos semanas y por
otro lado vemos una oposición que decían
las encuestas que iban a ganar en la
primera ronda o que al menos iban a
superar a erdogan y que van a ganar
la mayor parte de los asientos en el
parlamento y que no ha sido así entonces
los resultados son que nos han
sorprendido mucho a todos todo el mundo
está sorprendido erdogan se da por
ganador por supuesto la oposición está
está en horas bajas ahora mismo porque
porque Bueno hay una decepción con
respecto a las encuestas parecía que
iban a ganar pero no pero no ha sido así
y además la segunda vuelta probablemente
de a un erdogan como ganador porque
porque la oposición se ha visto muy
afectada por
unos resultados muy buenos de los de los
partidos más nacionalistas que son o
independientes o apoyan a ardogan
Entonces estos partidos nacionalistas
probablemente en una segunda vuelta
vayan por erdogan y erdogan finalmente
gane otra otra vez y que además los
nacionalistas están aliados con el akp
que es el partido oficialista de erdogan
y ellos son los que por ahora tendrían
Más escaños mucho más que la alianza
Nacional de los opositores entre las
sorpresas se cuenta el efecto que se
creía que iban a tener tanto la crisis
económica Como el terremoto porque por
un lado en este momento Turquía tiene
una de las inflaciones más altas de todo
el mundo con un 50 por ciento y del otro
han criticado duramente al gobierno de
erdoan por la falta de controles sobre
las constructoras que no cumpliendo
necesariamente con los requisitos
antisísmicos a pesar del largo historial
de fuertes terremotos en Turquía se
creía que esto le iba a pasar factura a
erdoan pero como usted nos dice pues por
ahora está saliendo victorioso Por qué a
qué se debe esto
Bueno pues eso ha sido una sorpresa muy
grande erdogan ha perdido podemos decir
que ha perdido muchos apoyos se puede
ver claramente en los resultados pero
aún así no han sido suficientes es más
en la zona del terremoto ese voto
castigo que se esperaba De hecho yo
estuve allí de traductor en el Hospital
Español de emergencia y mucha gente
decía que el estado les había abandonado
etcétera Pero a la hora la verdad hemos
visto que el gobierno de erdogan ha
sacado beneficio vamos a ganado
apoyos o incluso los que ha perdido no
han sido suficientes como para hacer un
efecto en el resultado de las elecciones
lo mismo con la con la crisis se decía
también que iba a haber una un voto
castigo muy fuerte aquí hay una una
crisis de él o sea una inflación del 50%
pero la inflación real o sea la
inflación del que dice el gobierno es de
50 pero la percibida es del 150 es muy
grave la crisis económica en la que está
Turquía y parece que aún así el voto
castigo que se esperaba no ha sido
insuficiente Y es que contrario a ese
voto castigo erdoan tiene una carta muy
fuerte a su favor y es el manejo de las
relaciones internacionales con las que
ha logrado posicionar a Turquía como una
potencia regional por ejemplo ha sido
determinante en guerras como las de
Siria y las de Libia y además ha servido
como mediador en el acuerdo de granos de
Ucrania y de Rusia mientras que del otro
lado
Blue se ha posicionado como un personaje
que se concentra más que todo en los
asuntos nacionales Usted cree que la
política exterior le jugó a favor a
erdogan en estos comicios
bueno la política exterior le ha jugado
a favor en el sentido de que erdoan
tiene un discurso muy identitario en su
política externa es un discurso de la
independencia de Turquía de la fuerza de
Turquía como un país independiente que
se que está inmiscuido en todos los
asuntos regionales pero al mismo tiempo
no es una política exterior muy
productiva en el sentido de que el
resultado suele ser negativo a nivel de
las incursiones en Siria el doble rasero
o con por un lado apoyando Ucrania y por
otro lado mejorando mucho las relaciones
con Rusia
eso le ha garantizado defender que
Turquía es independiente pero la al
mismo tiempo le ha garantizado la
enemistad con con Europa con la otan Y
probablemente si ganas elecciones estas
tensiones vayan en aumento en el caso de
que les da roblox él ha dicho que quiere
volcarse en
las relaciones con Europa volver
tomar ese acceso a la Unión Europea que
siempre está ahí que parece que sí pero
luego no y que les darólogo ha
fundamentado su Campaña en retomar esa
relación con Europa mientras que aquí
les daré Perdón
se ha fundamentado mucho más en esa
Independencia en esa fuerza
independiente
frente a las potencias extranjeras que
digamos parece que quieren hacer
interferencia no se puede decir entonces
que el claro ganador de estos comicios
es el nacionalismo Turco
sin duda sin duda al principio se decía
que iban a ser los kurdos los que iban a
decidir el resultado de las elecciones
pero resulta que no los que deciden el
resultado de las elecciones van a ser
los nacionalistas hay ahora mismo tres
partidos nacionalistas uno independiente
de sinan uno que está gobernando el mgp
con el don y otro que está con la
oposición y sin embargo la balanza
pensaba todo el mundo pensaba según las
encuestas que la balanza nacionalista se
va a inclinar a favor de que les darolo
y no ha sido así se ha inclinado a favor
de este partido independiente y a favor
del partido que apoya erdogan Entonces
sí son los nacionalistas definitivamente
los que deciden y van a decidir en dos
semanas Quién será el próximo presidente
elecciones sorpresivas entonces las que
hubo en Turquía Carlos Ortega Gracias
por estar con nosotros gracias a
vosotros y ustedes sigan conectados en
Flash 24 porque en segundos tenemos más
información
[Música]